oh
[Music]
oh
oh yes
you stopped
oh
oh
i already know she's in there i'm going
in there with a dog whether you want me
to or not
but
okay
what i need you to do is put him up on
me okay
okay
okay can you put him out i just i know
he's probably friendly but i know we're
strangers
here's something says i'm here for
two there's two reasons i'm here okay
her sons have wrecked and i'm trying to
get them in contact because i've got
family that live in jefferson city and i
know that they know her
okay so here's the other thing come on
now
look at him
on
you can
one more time
um
oh
[Applause]
she's trying to put the dog
hello
are you okay no you shot me
watch out
are you okay no you shot me oh god are
you okay
oh my god
no 1081.
echo 7 1081.
i hit her i hit her
hey
hey you're all right
talk to me what yes talk to me just the
leg yeah the one leg
tell me when it starts really hurting
the tourniquet okay
is the tourniquet hurting yet no
keep twisting
i got we got to get fourth step they're
coming jordan i call him alright
are you okay charlie
can you hear me yeah
are you okay
for talking jordan you're gonna be fine
you're gonna have a hell of a story here
no
it's
hey lydia yeah
a lot more exciting than leeds huh yeah
are you okay uh yeah i don't know you're
gonna be good you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be just fine
everything's so hot
yeah it's hot in hell out here no my
legs
oh
oh
[Applause]
i won't get you to the car just stand up
for just a second okay okay
okay
cool
whoever's in that blue lights on this
driver
you're right
you're on the flat there you go
right here right here right here
left side
i got him
i got her somebody just give me some
light so i can see
get us a watch
get it for me
oh
shut the door